نعم في تطور لافت مسؤول دفاعي امريكي
ابلغنا للتو بان ما وصفه بالتحالف الذي
استهدف مواقع انصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن مؤلف من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
لكن هذه العمليه دعمتها كل من استراليا
كندا
هولندا بالاضافه الى البحرين المسؤول رفض
الافصاح عن طبيعه هذا الدعم الذي قدمته
هذه الدول ذكر هذه الدول التي دعمت هذه
العمليه العسكريه في استهداف مواقع تابعه
لانصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن هي
استراليا كندا هولندا
والبحرين قال بانه يترك لهذه الدول ان
تتحدث عن طبيعه الدعم الذي قدمته وحول
التقارير التي اشارت الى استهداف سفن
حربيه امريكيه من قبل انصار الله الحوثيين
هذا المسؤول اشار الى انه حتى هذه اللحظه
ليس هناك اي معطيات تتعلق بتعرض اي سفينه
امريكيه حربيه في منطقه البحر الاحمر لاي
هجوم وبانه لم يتم الابلاغ حتى هذه اللحظه
عن اي اضرار او هجمات وبالتالي نذكر مره
اخرى ما قاله للتو مسؤول دفاعي امريكي بان
هذه العمليه هي عباره عن عمليه شنها تحالف
مؤلف من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ضد
مواقع تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن وتلقى هذا التحالف دعما من قبل
استراليا كندا هولندا والبحرين
نعم